so 1993 I was in it I wasn't a vendor
and I was at a typical midsize company
growing and we were using file sharing
based email and we had not had any sort
of historical Legacy Mainframe systems
we were never on profs or anything like
that and we just had grown up this email
culture and as we were growing as a
company uh you couldn't just go go down
the hall and say let's have a meeting it
had to start getting a formalized
structure from when it was 200 people in
one building to a thousand people across
the campus so were people using
electronic calendars then not really
there was a lot of file effects and you
know whatever daytimers and the like and
on paper yeah and
um uh you know email to try to
coordinate calendars but but that was
that was pretty much it in that company
um some of the very earliest pdas were
just starting to come out M so the hp95
LX was like one of the first handheld
flip up devices that had CC mail built
into it um some people had Palm Pilots
or Palms that they they were just Palms
at the time uh and you know we're
starting to use that but really for the
most part electronic calendaring wasn't
in the environment it wasn't in the
workplace uh unless you had been in a
big company that had IBM profs and a
main FR that was kind of the only
so those people were used to oh yeah
well my calendar's just on my system
that wasn't a very good calendar but it
was there closed environment you had it
we didn't have any of that okay um and
none of the filesharing vendors had any
kind of uh calendaring Service as part
of their email systems there was nothing
with CC mail there was nothing with
Microsoft Mail uh uh work perfect office
eventally added calendar but it wasn't
it wasn't initially there either so the
industry in the early '90s was just
starting to recognize calendaring Lotus
acquired a company called threads in the
UK and they made organizer and so Lotus
had this Pim product Lotus organizer and
then they undertook in 93 the
engineering to make Lotus organizer a
group caliber product okay and as a cc
mail customer with these kind of
problems in our business we were
extremely interested in what Lotus was
going to do there Microsoft also started
doing with schedule plus which some
added to Microsoft Mail and you know so
it sort of got born in the distributed
environment 93 time frame so why do you
think the counter was merged with mail I
think transport was really the main
reason everybody already got email in
the organization so it was the only
system in most companies that touched
everyone and if I could piggy back on
that to do some other business workflow
especially something as horizontal as
calendaring I think that that was
probably the logic
um and in fact the early versions of
lotus organizer didn't do anything in
the mail system your invites and all
that stuff were separate when you
launched Lotus organizer you saw them
but they were called out of your inbox
by the organizer program essentially as
a hack right it would go into your inbox
and look for keywords and pull those
over into Lotus organizer but you did
all your workflow and calendar stuff in
the calendar then it wasn't like you
were in your inbox and saw an invitation
okay I just want to see if everything
working all
right actually this is good by the way I
I didn't even know that the early
versions of U of uh of uh calendar were
actually separated from the
mail it just used males as transport
that was all it was and it was uh and
also I guess it's a good distribution
channel right like you you basically say
well if I want to get calendar in the
hands of a lot of people at the end of
the day put it with the mail right well
and it had a directory already so was
that you know but the individual
calendars were individual files they
weren't in any kind of shared database
they had to go on an H drive on the
network or whatever but it was a it was
it was a it was a single file that was
my.org or O2 or whatever and I could
copy that to my local drive if I was
working on a at home or on a laptop or
whatever not that everybody had laptops
at that time either but um you know not
many at all did yeah but it was very
single user Centric and very um cluing
it just was yeah but but it somehow
worked okay and then from so so then
what was the next logical step from
there so then in uh kind of the mid 90s
is when um the client server messaging
era sort of started to take off with
lotus with notes V4 and Microsoft with
exchange right and exchange 96
originally just used a Microsoft male
client but then in out they introduced
Outlook in
9797 and that was a combined mail and
calendar client and Lotus introduced
noes
4.5 with an integrated calendar that we
had based Loosely on the features of
organizer uh in 1997 we also made
organizer work on top of notes what were
what were customers saying like back
then
like calendaring became a a requirement
driven by it by it yeah yeah just as a
this is another service we want to
provide as part of our Enterprise
Communications infrastructure now that
we see the technology is available we
want it and we want it in this
environment and a lot of companies that
had never gone through a fil sharing
based email system were still on
mainframes we're on profs were're on uh
deck Allin one you know all these other
sort of Prior generation mail systems
that it had calendaring so they were
like well if I'm going to move to client
server it's got to have a calendar so
that was really the impetus for us to
get that into the product uh in the 96
97 time frame okay and and then so that
so that calendar that you started to put
in there
uh like when did it become uh when did
the switch happen from saying okay it's
my calendar versus I want to start
sharing it with other people when the
and what was the reason people started
to want a calendar
share um I think
that some corporate cultures really
drove the idea that I want to I want
everybody to be able to see what my
calendar is my department I want to be
able to choose people to know where I'm
at there were hard the mechanisms
weren't easy to distribute that
information any other way uh most of the
email systems didn't even have an outof
the office kind of a function at that
point not an effective one so you know
putting my calendar online was an easy
way to tell my work group or my
department or my building or whatever
where I was and and even the earliest
versions of notes and Outlook had some
level of privacy controls or whatever
that I could just publish free time or I
could just publish my calendar or
whatever and I think that the
organizational need was just to be able
to know where people were and as
companies sort of that were distributed
across multiple sites uh started to work
together more using other current
generation collaborative tools okay and
and and did that need then evolve into
something else after that or or was it
really I want to know what people in my
organization are doing I think the
evolution from there
was how do I schedule conference rooms
how do I think about really truly doing
meetings this way and not just just
Personal Diary info how do I sync that
to something that's a local device of
some kind or at least have access to it
at home so the usage patterns did
definitely change from the initial you
sort of our 4.5 release okay to to now
the the use of calendaring has become
part and parcel of every deployment you
know for a while there will be
introduced it about half customer said
we're not going to use that we're just
using it as an email system what we have
apps but calendar right now in 2010 I I
think pretty much every notes customer
uses the calendar I'm sure that Outlook
users would say exactly the same thing
which